hey this is presh talwalkar
what's the probability you draw a pair
of aces from a deck
in this question i'm going to ask you to
calculate it for two different
circumstances
we'll simplify things that you have a
deck with only four cards it has the ace
of spades the ace of clubs the two of
spades and the two of clubs
you shuffle this deck of cards and you
draw two cards
what is the probability the two cards
you drew are aces
under two different circumstances
circumstance one you know at least one
card is an ace
and circumstance two
you know one card is the ace of spades
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
i'm first going to present the
theoretical calculation and then i'm
going to show how you can numerically
estimate the probability in a
spreadsheet
so the surprising part about this
problem is that the answers are
different
when you draw two cards from a deck
there are six equally likely ways you
can draw the cards
you can draw the ace of spades with any
of the other three cards
you can draw the ace of clubs with the
other twos or you can draw the pair of
twos
if you know that you've drawn at least
one ace then you can eliminate the
possibility of having drawn the pair of
twos
this leaves five equally likely events
in exactly one of these events you've
drawn a pair of aces
so the probability you've drawn a pair
of aces if you know there's at least one
ace is one divided by five
what would happen if you knew you drove
the ace of spades
in that case the ace of spades could be
paired with any of the other three cards
there are three equally likely events
exactly one of those has a pair of aces
so in this case there is a probability
of one divided by three
and this is surprising that the detail
that you drew the ace of spades actually
affects the probability
the conditional probability is effective
because your knowledge is different in
these two different circumstances
now whenever i do a video like this
people always question whether the
probability is accurate
so i'm going to show you that this is
the correct probability in a numerical
estimate in a spreadsheet it's going to
take a lot of time to do it but it's
worth the time to watch the video
let's set up a spreadsheet so that we
can numerically estimate the
probabilities
we'll start by writing down the things
we want to calculate
in one case we want to calculate the
probability we have both aces if we have
at least one ace in the draw
in the other case we want to calculate
the probability we have both aces
if we have the ace of spades
as we do our trials we're going to want
to keep track of the number of times the
trials meet these conditions
so we have a deck with four cards we
have the ace of spades
the ace of clubs
the two of spades and the two of clubs
we're going to draw two random cards
from this deck
we then check whether the cards meet our
conditions
so how are we going to draw two random
cards from this deck
it's not as simple as simply generating
random numbers because we want to make
sure that the two random numbers we
generate are not equal to each other
so here's how we're going to do it we're
going to be drawing without replacement
imagine the ace of spades is numbered as
one the ace of clubs number two
two of spades is number three
and two of clubs is number four
so if we can generate two different
numbers between one and four
that'll be like picking out those two
cards from the deck
in order to do that i'm going to
generate four random numbers between
zero and one
these will all be different random
numbers and that's the key
if you look at the first random number
we generate
it's going to be the second highest out
of these four values so that's as if
we're drawing the second card from this
deck
if you look at this random number it's
the highest so it's as if we drew the
ace of spades
so i'm simply going to convert these
numbers the rank of these numbers
into the different cards
to do that we'll use the index formula
we set up a reference row of our deck of
cards they'll be numbered from one to
four
now i want to draw the rank
of this first random number
relative to the four random numbers
so we'll verify this formula works
the random number that we're looking up
is going to be the lowest it's the
fourth rank out of these four random
numbers
so that would be the two of clubs and we
did in fact draw the two of clubs
so i'm going to do the same thing for
the second card
we start out with our deck of cards but
now i'm going to draw a different rank
the rank of the second
column
so this will ensure that i'm drawing a
different card from the deck but it is
also going to be random because it is
relative to these random numbers
so now i've drawn two random number two
random cards from our deck and now we
need to check whether these conditions
are met
so there are different ways you could do
this i'm going to write out formulas in
a kind of a long way
so let's check if both of them are aces
well there are two ways that that can
happen
that can be if the first card is the ace
of spades and the other card is the ace
of clubs
or it could happen the other way
where the first card is the ace of clubs
and the second card is equal to the ace
of spades
now if these conditions are true
i'm going to put a 1
and otherwise i'll put a 0. i have to
make sure i typed everything carefully
and i've put all the
parentheses in the proper places so that
looks correct
now let's check if one of these cards
that we drew is the ace of spades
or sorry if one of these cards is an ace
so this can be if the first card is a
ace of spades or equal to the ace of
clubs
or the second card
is equal to the ace of spades or the ace
of clubs
now if this is true i'll put a 1
otherwise i'll put a 0 if it's not true
now i need to check if either card
is equal
to the ace of spades
either the first card or the second card
if that's true i'll put a one otherwise
i'll put a zero
so now it took a lot of work but we've
set up a way that we're drawing two
random cards from this deck and we're
checking the conditions
now i'm going to want to paste these
formulas down but before i do that i
want to make sure
that the deck of cards doesn't shift
because if i don't do that otherwise
these references will all go down one
so i'm going to put dollar signs which
means that the references to these
values of the deck of the card stays the
same
so now if i copy this down to the next
row
it's as if i've shuffled a deck of cards
i've picked up two different random
cards from this deck
and i'm checking all these conditions
so that's the beauty of doing this in a
spreadsheet
rather than having to physically shuffle
a deck
take out two cards and then check the
conditions i can simply paste down these
formulas into a new row
and i've simulated a new trial
now in order to get a good estimate of
these probabilities i'm going to want to
do this many many times so let's say i
paste this down
for 10 000 trials
so now i've pasted these formulas down
and i've done 10 000 shuffles of the
deck so you could never physically do
this this quickly
but numerically i can now figure out the
proportion of times our different
conditions are met
so the number of times we have both aces
will be the sum in this column
the number of times we have
at least one ace will be the sum in the
next column over
and then the number of times we have the
ace of spades will be the sum in the
next column over
another way to explain this is i've set
up indicator barrier variables for the
different conditions
so now i can calculate the probabilities
that we actually want let's estimate
these
the probability that we have both aces
divided by the given that we have at
least one ace will be this ratio
and now we have the probability that we
have both aces divided by the
probability we have the ace of spades as
one of the cards
so we have about 0.00
0.20 and 0.34
so these will remind me of the numbers 1
over 5
and one over three
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker
and if you like this video please check
out my books their links in the video
description